okay i usually don't do this but i want
to do a quick
intro before the video begins so a few
weeks ago i met with grandmaster aman
hamilton
of chess bra on stream and
we basically taught each other all the
different tricky openings and traps
and very rare ideas that that we know
i learned a lot i'm sure he learned a
lot i think it was super
educational for the viewers and
we we not only kind of discussed and
analyzed ideas but we also played
games against viewers where we teamed up
and tried to come up with uh with even
more novel ideas
so i think there's a ton of value in
this and what i'm going to do is
put time stamps for every different kind
of segment
and opening that we cover so feel free
to kind of skip around
and look at the openings that are most
interesting to you
on top of that i will link a leachate
study
which i just created um
and by the time this video is posted uh
the the chapters will hopefully be a bit
more kind of thorough and annotated
but these are all of the kind of
different
ideas that we looked at some are full
games
some are opening traps but i think
there's a ton of things that people can
learn
um if you're a beginner or even if
you're a more experienced player
a lot of these these lines that we
covered
can be very effective in blitz and also
can catch even strong players off guard
so without further ado
i'll let the video play and uh and i
hope you enjoy it
and also feel free to leave comments
with any questions
or any recommendations of what you would
like to see in the future
yes we got mr rosen here it's a it's a
privilege
a pleasure yeah no i i think this is our
first
like real collaboration yes
it is and it's surprising at that
yeah no i i think i was on your channel
like once
when i first moved here it was like the
first week and fabiano came over
and there was some like blindfold chess
i remember
um yeah yeah it was fun but
uh yeah looking forward to there's a lot
of people
um i think a lot of people do know but
i'm willing to say there's a good
percentage that
like don't know that we like share the
place
in in st louis and that uh i think i was
reading a nice
article of yours some interview about
like the chess boom and it's a
little chess bra billboard in the
background
in your setup there well when i um when
i first moved here
it was april 1st and i posted a tweet
saying i'm moving into the chest bra
apartment and no one believed it
understandable and i think
understandable
several months later people like began
to realize that it was true
so it was a slight trick we didn't think
uh we didn't think the announcement date
through
very well we should have coordinated it
yeah i'll get comments from time to time
like people now know like i kind of
live in and i share an apartment with
you guys and then there's comments
asking
how are we both streaming at the same
time if we share the same place
right i don't think they realize like
you're also kind of based in canada
so yeah like primarily based in canada
and i guess pre-pre-covered i i think
it's fair to say we spent a
like a good chunk uh of time in st louis
kind of going back and forth so we would
actually
cross paths a lot more often than than
lately
definitely yeah yeah and um i feel like
we
both kind of have this traveling
lifestyle to
uh pre-covered where um
like at least last year i remember i
feel like
last time i saw eric like you guys were
about to go to japan or something
um maybe that was the last uh
last like international trip for a while
yeah my
i actually maybe was the person that
traveled
like most recently um like
maybe anyone in the world i played a
chess tournament in czech republic
in prague and it was like february so
it's like right before they closed
like absolutely everything so that's
good timing
yeah i snuck one in nice yeah
yeah my last trip was uh i went to
israel for 10 days in january
so it was also like decent timing yep
but then i wanted to go to like vietnam
in march and then all of that just fell
through
yeah yeah we had a few plans that fell
through but
hoping to pick up where we left off you
know as soon as we can
for sure so um what did you have in mind
for
uh like i i know like tricky okay tricky
openings and dubious gambits or whatever
it will be the theme did you want to
play each other or
um are we gonna play subscribers or
yeah so first and foremost like i know
that
you're pretty flexible and i am as well
so i just i was like
i like you honestly i'm a big fan myself
of the
like your youtube and the videos that
you make and i was thinking that they
align
so well with the videos that i like to
make where it's just kind of playing
like
slightly intentionally subpar stuff with
some great
uh tricks and honestly it works like a
good percentage of time and people
really enjoy that kind of stuff so i was
thinking
the way that i usually do those is you
know i get games against
people and either i'm trying things that
i've i've already sort of worked out or
i have an idea
might be tricky enough and worth a try
or i
you know just play a crazy move and i i
just repeat it enough times that i call
it an opening at the end of the day
so i guess i was figuring we might start
with um
playing some games against other people
and see if we you know come up with
anything fancy or
if you have some i know you have some
openings that i probably haven't even
seen you know some some tricky openings
uh that you've done some videos on that
maybe people in my chat haven't been
exposed to as much
yeah no no this is one of my biggest
loves in
chess is like tricky gambits and weird
openings and
especially like when it comes to blitz
and bullet i have a whole kind of
separate
trappy repertoire um and also like
especially against
lower rated players too there's certain
lines that
just beginners are more likely to just
walk into and lose quickly
so yeah exactly and as you might have
seen
as you may have seen from my
over-the-board tournament
my my crappy dubious openings have you
know leaked into my classical chess as
well
so yeah no i was um
i was so amazed watching your game i
think it was against steven zurich
exactly in this tournament uh like this
high level gm norm tournament where
you're playing this dumb
england gambit queen sack and you got to
like a table based drawn position
after like yeah exactly exactly
it did it's it did its job honestly i
didn't do my job as a chess player but
it did its job
as an opening and ironically i think
that was my last time that i was in st
louis ah yeah
there you go so i i actually made like a
small
list of openings i'm happy to like share
with you
that maybe you haven't encountered
or um and like i tried to have a list
that are like
it's relatively they're relatively rare
openings
so um i'd be happy to like have an
analysis board or we can just
jump straight into playing sure well do
you want to start maybe
um like um going over a few
things from that list yeah let's do it
then we can see if we like have some
favorites and try to get them instant
games
sounds good the pro so the problem with
showing them
is there's some like trappy lines which
if i show them people aren't going to
walk into but
i can still show them and um maybe maybe
maybe you just
maybe you just show me and i look at it
off stream and we
we team up against the chat that might
be better
um yeah there's a few ways to do it um i
mean some of them yeah
i can show and like they're it's more
about just getting like a
novel position from early on yeah
because i've actually noticed that
maybe one of the um
one of the differences that i think
let's say low-rated players or even
unsuspecting players is a more accurate
term um
might fall into is they think like
that oh if it's if it's not good on the
engine it's not
a good opening but oftentimes especially
with some of the sacrifices or
crazy lines i like to play i people know
what the position
is they know the best line against it
they still play it
and they still lose like it's you know
it doesn't necessarily
beat the opening or something yeah no
this is this is an issue with a lot of
players as though they'll just
see the numbers cheers
cheers getting alerts that
makes it difficult for me to talk um but
yeah that
i guess my main point is the engine
doesn't reflect
how difficult a position is to play and
there's positions which can be
like plus two for white but are really
really difficult to play
yeah and those are the sort of positions
i i really strive to
to try and get yes there's like this
sweet spot
yeah so like my favorite i'm sure you're
aware of this is like stafford gambit
is one example of this where it's
instantly plus two for white and
there's a lot of lines which um
so-called like refute
opening but even those lines like
they're still really difficult to play
and it requires a lot of precise moves
which yeah most players won't well no
and even stronger players won't be able
to figure out
and the i guess the best the best part
is um that no matter what you're doing
you're doing it extremely quickly
because you know the ins and outs
so at the very least you're guaranteed
some sort of time edge right
exactly yeah no and this is a great
thing when um
i guess when it comes to blitzer bullet
is if you're prepared in these like
offbeat dubious lines
at the very least you're going to get a
time advantage
and that can be enough uh when it comes
to compensation
so yeah if you want to jump into like
some kind of analysis board
yeah i can share hopefully a few secrets
i'm just uh going to log into different
accounts i'll be on um
i'll be on kmvb okay and
okay yeah i'm looking at my list here uh
showing it on my screen i think i'll
show you one
that i like almost positive you probably
haven't seen before
and it's inspired it's just like a three
move
opening and that's nice and simple
it requires so it requires black to play
like
i guess the two most natural moves on
move one
uh and you can start with either e3 or
knight c3
but it it just requires a combination of
these two moves
um so let's say knight c3 um
most players will play either e5 or d5
yeah
um and what you're going for
is this position
um and i'll give some backstory because
uh
i first learned about logical enough
yeah so i first learned about this line
a few years ago like some one of my
webster teammates just casually
mentioned this
as like a cool like tricky line and then
more recently i was watching an xqc
video
he was playing vr chess and
he played knight c3 and e3
and um it reminded me of like this
this opening that i was told about like
years ago
um and the move to play here is queen h5
and like all of a sudden if if black
doesn't play precisely
white is uh like
applying a lot a lot of pressure to
black
yeah if you just try and think what to
do for black
without an engine ideally yeah like it's
not something i imagine
imagine the the i mean knight c6 seems
like the
move that most people would play
yeah so we're attacking the e5 pawn
we're preventing f6
and um the bishop d6
would defend e5 but lose d5 so after
knight c6 we played bishop b5
yeah yeah and like the combination of
the knight bishop and queen they're
applying pressure in like so many
different ways
um and then on top of that like we're
ready to play knight f3 or even f4 or d4
in some cases
so i'll admit i haven't studied this
like so deeply with
with engine but um from a practical
standpoint
it's fun for white yeah and like most
most moves lose a pawn i would say
almost
all moves loose upon here like the
natural moves yeah like what you
what you do v6 queen e7 bishop e6
they all drop something as he said f6 is
impossible like we're threatening to
take this pawn and like the natural
moves to the fan
e5 will lose d5 yeah um
so i think queen d6 is probably the best
move here
um and then we can continue um i think
knight f3
or d4 are both playable and it just guts
you kind of get a novel position from
early on
with the queen the queen on g6 is a bit
weird for black
exactly no i i i like it already because
it seems like uh
it doesn't require a lot for your
opponent to
enter it like who isn't really going to
play d5 and e5
on the first couple moves like they
might not but i think you're dealing
with good percentages here
yeah no it's it's a very likely
possibility i mean if if they play
knight f6
then you can still kind of um
get kind of a a novel position with f4
and then play somewhat of a reverse
dutch
or the so-called polar bear setup with
um like the knight f3 b3 and bishop b2
and then you go for like the the middle
game kingside attack
so um i went through a phase a little
bit where i was trying to develop a
rapper tour around this line
but uh yeah and it seems to me like
maybe starting with knight c3
is the more provocative way to start it
seems like you'll get them
playing d5 and e5 more if you start with
knight than if you start with e3
that's very true yeah because they'll be
like oh
you know what the hell is this i'm just
going to take the center this guy
doesn't know how to play but e3 it's
like you know they'll probably play
maybe e5 but um yeah it might not follow
up with d5 so
i like knight c3 it seems like the the
bait move no for sure
and i mean there's some weird people who
will play c5
like the sicilian players and then those
weirdos like you can transpose into
close sicilian or
uh you could maybe keep it weird and do
this and then have like a reverse
this is like a reverse night's tango um
so there's opportunities to keep it uh
unique
to the repertoire yep
i'm a big fan of that so this is
actually similar and just another
opening
like on my list it actually um happened
in a recent hikaru magnus
game and you you probably at least saw
it
it came from an english opening okay
um and it basically uses the same idea
of let me see if i can remember i think
it's e3
actually it doesn't matter between e3 or
knight c3 but you play both of these
moves
let's say black goes for like the most
common um like reverse open sicilian
takes takes and then queen h5 here was
played by magnus
yeah um and magnus just crushed shikaru
without
really any effort like he won the pawn
from the opening after knight c6 bishop
b5
i forgot exactly what happened i think
karo went for some knight before move
queen d6 should be played at some point
but hikaru just went for like counter
play and then it didn't work because
queen takes and then queen e4
defended the the light squares um
so just another cool idea that you can
potentially use totally relatable
english
yeah especially pretty much the same
thing exactly
especially like world like one of the
top blitz players in the world doesn't
uh
wasn't prepared for this yeah the karu
so
yeah whenever you see this this queen h5
i mean some people like to play the
i don't even know what they call it like
the passers-opening or something it's
like the e4 e5
and you you bring the the queen out
super early
and uh and even that is like you know
tricky enough for
for certain levels but this looks like
the advanced version of that
the more reliable version definitely and
like if you check with engine
white's not i mean
white's maybe um a little bit worse
but like black again has to play
precisely
i think the best case scenario is like
some
close to equality so and are
most of your like do you do you look
do you actively look up um interesting
or dubious things or are they often born
of
maybe like you know a game against
someone where you're intentionally
trying to like mess around or spice up
the position it just turns into
something
that's a good question um i guess
it's a mix of different things
i'm just passionate about like exploring
new lines in general
so all i'll often like encounter
just weird i'll i'll actively seek out
like
players who play kind of weird openings
um i mean richard rapport is
kind of a role model uh timor grave does
insane things
um so i guess having
having some role models is nice but then
um also like i guess one of the things
that's helped is
playing like playing a lot of viewers on
stream
like i'm constantly playing amateur
players
and then i'll kind of get a sense of
what works well against those players
and i'll keep experimenting with trappy
lines
yep yeah i think what you touched on at
the end is pretty much
nearly 100 of where it comes from for me
it's just
just like playing uh you know
subscribers or viewers
it like entirely shifts the way that i
play because
you know i i won't just like go 100 try
hard mode
to like wipe them off the board every
time and sometimes i might sack a piece
and then i'll learn to play
a certain way a more solid way trying to
avoid trades
and you know sometimes i might sack a
pawn or i might just throw in g4 just to
throw it in
sure so so yeah it's usually usually
born
of something something like that for me
where i'm just intentionally kind of
messing around
and hey it works out sometimes but
oftentimes it backfires so
you know you have to take your take your
losses with with this strategy as well
another thing that helps is to i know
it's sometimes hard to discipline
yourself but to go
over every game that you play and then
look for like small improvements or look
for the
the weird ideas that you could perhaps
use in the future
and then another thing i guess i didn't
mention is
just getting recommendations from twitch
chat
i all on occasion like take opening
requests or people will just
tell me weird lines i've never heard of
before
um and then that can lead to some
some discovery of some hidden gems
so i probably actually say half the
openings i i discover these days are
from twitch chat uh
something like this they're passionate
about weird things
oh they definitely are chats are
non-chess related they definitely have
their their passions but
i think the two um like the the
undefeated opening that i like to play
um is definitely one that i
happened to invent which was like is it
separate from a twitch thing
and it was it was honestly like kind of
lucky that i was trying to show someone
the classic
like the classic trap and it kind of
backfired because the guy was really
good
and i was trying to demonstrate how you
know hey this is
you know a trap they can fall into and
then he played knight c3 and i was like
well
wait a minute i actually have no idea
what to do and like the guy's like
gonna play an 85 and start like winning
the game and
and then just to stack the queen here
was was purely based off that and the
fact that i often give queen odds to
the viewers anyway um whereas the other
two that
i've played a lot on my channel uh like
the the fred
and the jerome are two two openings
which i've played quite a bit of and
those were actually
twitch chat being like hey have you
heard of this and just the names of both
of those
openings like they're just first names
of people they just sounded so funny to
me i had to investigate them
so those were the two that that i've
played uh thanks to twitch
nice yeah yeah i feel like you kind of
spiked the popularity for
i mean this england and okay i haven't
seen this too much
or too often uh this is fred
i i think there's there is um
there was a quip a twitch clip a while
ago
of magnus being interviewed and he was
sharing
like a playable thread defense
which emerges from some vienna gambit
i i won't be able to remember it but um
it comes from like white plays it
and it involves whites playing an
early f4
i'm not going to remember it like it's
like an f4 followed by a king f2
type of thing something yeah it might be
this
line with takes and then like d4
[Music]
so this is a line um in itself this is
called the
chess.com we'll know
yeah i thought that was called the no
kunski gambit
but this is like a playable blonde cloud
definitely
um and this has been featured in like
high level grand master games
uh where even though white like white's
king is ridiculous we play knight f3 we
attack the queen and
um the center kind of gives white some
compensation
yep um i think asparav actually played
this in one of the like st louis rapid
and blitz events
uh within the last few years yeah
there's a few but the great thing about
f4 is that like
i mean you can play like this is another
line
and just go king f1 if you're not not so
ambitious with king e2 but the nice
thing about f4
as white is you kind of have the
initiative in most lines and
you get that thrill of uh moving your
king without castling
definitely yeah and like if you're a
beginner
or like at a lower level queen h4 looks
so enticing
for black but then it's white who gets
initiative with knight f3
and i think this is effective for a lot
of players um
and you can even start with uh you don't
even need knight c3 like if you play
this position
just play the immediate bishop c4
and i know this has this has a name
of some sort um the names i'm terrible
with
i'm bad with them too yeah like people
will say like have you heard of so and
so opening in the chat and
um i'll usually need notation to to
assist
well it helps a little bit if it's like
you know jerome and fred are easier
because they're like they're like
people's names
so that's a little more helpful to
remember
but um yeah i mean we can uh we can just
try to get in some games and see yeah
let's do it if you wanna
i can observe you yeah i was gonna say
we can take
chat with different challenges like i
know i can play one and then you can
play one you can follow
sounds good um follow along so i mean to
i guess speaking to people in
both chats um i know your username is
i am rosen mine is kn v
[Music]
nice and short um so yeah if you want to
send some challenges and i don't know i
usually go
less than five minute games as a as a
rule to
get thank you yeah get get some
different
uh opponents in there but yeah i mean
pretty much any rating
any uh any time control less than less
than five minutes is uh
will work and i mean i'm not gonna be
able to maybe get something every game
but
i think you'll actually i think you have
a more diverse
like a wider set of options for like
uh you know if someone plays c4 or d4 e4
you have something whereas like
i have a really good option if they play
certain things but not
not all the time well maybe i i can
hopefully give you some uh some
inspiration to
exactly in your repertoire that's
that's why i'm here i want to build i
want to build off uh
some of your advice so here do you want
me to start i'll do the first game
yeah let's do it do you um should i like
is it okay if i tell you what to do in
some cases i think that's the i think
that's definitely the point like
it's pretty much like you and i against
someone but we'll try to keep it as like
as messy and try to get the the most fun
position
possible okay yeah so maybe it's better
if people challenge the casual or
like unrated oh yeah i guess i forgot to
mention i
in in my chat it's a it's a regular
thing all my challenges are unrated
because
um at this point they've taken so much
of my reading that now my rating is so
low that you know they're worried about
their rate
you know they don't want me to take it
back so
unrated is good i'm trying to figure out
how to
follow oh i guess i can just use the
command
yeah if you slash follow came to be
the chest.com chat box there sweet
that should work as well okay i think
i'm following you now
cool okay so i will take a game here
and take one here from
1546 from australia
all right we're white and i feel like
most most
interesting openings are born and bred
from e4 and
unless i'm playing knight c3 no no
london system
well the london i feel like uh you know
is i've already exhausted all the traps
and believe me i love looking for traps
in london but
yeah that's something i can probably
spend hours talking about
um there's a few like tricky lines but
uh oh okay okay i like what i'm saying
already
we'll start with something simple uh
okay we're obviously gonna go
here i'm waiting for that queen h4 move
yeah yeah he's uh he's being quite
friendly right now
this is nice
and when it works this well then you
know you can start to build an opening
repertoire around
allowing queen h4 just as long as the
king goes to e2 i'm sure
there's a full bomb cloud repertoire
available out there
yeah no it's a very uh reliable bomb
cloud
oh defying opening principles
well you want to try to to get your king
to e2 with tempo i feel like if i had
played voluntarily
i look bad so i'm really trying to beat
that queen over
mm-hmm
[Music]
and the nice thing is now i guess you
don't have to worry about queen h4
yes but that's kind of what we were
hoping for so
exactly so my plan was to play e5
and and make sure that queen h4 is
available again
yeah oh
c takes very anti-positional
yep but he's maybe doing the same thing
as us he's trying to spice the game up
yeah this is already like pawn structure
i've never seen before
yeah honestly i can i can say might be
the first time i've ever seen this
and it's been a while since i've played
king's gambit
but i have some vague memory of having
having games like resembling at least
okay not this exact position but kind of
the
resulting development scheme and there's
there's cases where black can easily
fall for a greek gift
right yeah 100.
so i'm hoping that doesn't discourage
our opponent i don't know if our
opponent is watching but
uh maybe we can hopefully he's watching
but not listening that's that's the
sweet spot
that's true so we still we're still
looking
for queen h4 i like this bishop c4 move
because black can't really defend oh
there it is
it worked oh we got i don't know if i'm
like supposed to be super happy with
this
but this looks like a a win i get to
play my teammate too
i mean it's important to play king e2
and not king f1 because
first of all bong cloud but secondly
if knight e3 then we can take twice and
our king
can become active exactly and
at this point i think he's uh he's just
helping
helping me develop i really can't
complain
yeah it was helpful that he played f3
otherwise maybe knight f3 would have
been
harder to find yeah i i wasn't sure
about my next move but
f3 kind of forced me
and these two would be the unfortunate
mistake
of the century it's funny like earlier
after bishop c4 i was going to say that
black doesn't have a good way of
defending the knights
but i think black found the only way to
and defeat now of course we have to
you got a jerome delayed jerome yes
combined with the
delayed king's gambit pawn cloud
the whole thing worked out brilliantly
and the knight's gonna have an outpost
created by my opponent's c takes v6 move
i mean
obviously we keep it oh that's g6 square
gotta develop the king because if you
didn't play d5
there were potentially some really
grotesque checkmates there
now this is a difficult situation oh
okay i was going to say
you could on passant but i guess knight
d6 is more powerful
so i at this point in the in the game i
i am only exclusively thinking of like
where a very very sexy checkmate might
lie
it is pretty close
so i'm going to try
i'm going to try to go for like
i actually really like that move d5
e6 type of push that's what i'm thinking
oh that's a that's an interesting
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna respect it
that's a strong move
yeah bishop h4 there's g5 and bishop
would get trapped
so i want to open things up queen g4 is
looking tempting but let's see yeah
see if there's any meats here no oh okay
three minutes i would be panicking with
this time
let's give a chat
there we go oh
see if we can get a pawn mate or
something damn it
yeah watch your time
okay we'll pre-move this one
[Laughter]
you know the worst part did i a mate
knight c7 if i didn't move
uh okay no i didn't blocked it
yeah i mean that's i was going to win i
was going rook f1 to try to get uh
like a nightmare somewhere ah
and his bishop at five was better than i
gave it credit for
no the opponent was very resourceful and
playing like
a great move that's exactly how you you
don't
allow you know
yourself i mean that was such a
beautiful game on so many levels too
bishop f7 you know like the it's nice
how we incorporated a few techniques in
there
bong cloud and jerome it's kind of like
a masterpiece
yeah no that doesn't happen every day in
some ways i think his best move was
actually
thought do you think
it really freed him from his shackles oh
yeah i know it helps the bishop develop
the knights of d6 i'm i'm picturing some
nasty mates
where the king runs to d8 and c7
it's just stuck there oh there's so many
possibilities
i like it that was that was definitely a
good start but yeah you know
the right energy oh for sure
f4 yeah that game worked out pretty well
that was just king's bandit
but i think in general the king's gambit
has a really high ceiling for turning
into like a
like a stop just getting getting e4 d4
pawns
um against low-rated players often leads
to
really active positions with lots of
tactics
yeah and most players who are rated like
less than 1800
won't really know what to do and they'll
just let you get a massive center
right it's so fun exactly
gg alpacas so here i'll follow you now
yeah
i just realized uh there's a like with
chess.com you can have a challenge link
it's chess.com play slash username
so i'm going to add that yeah i have a
exclamation mark challenge link in my
chat and yeah it's like
chess.com um knbb i have a whole bunch
of other things
after my link like some numbers i'm not
sure if they're necessary oh or you can
like have the default
time control something that people can
figure out
yeah i just added a chest challenge
command now now i'm getting challenges
there you go uh oh people are listening
everything's unrated and
blitz that's a very respectable i always
have a few guys sneaking a rated one
that's where all my reading disappears
okay i'm gonna play
i'm gonna play the highest rated person
challenging me which is snell
6969 oh they have the chest bra flare
okay so i'm going to play my um my
tricky gambit repertoire
which uh it starts with e5
oh they're they're okay
they want to play a gambit so i'm gonna
play the counter gambit
this is actually a fun line so here as
white when people play this against me
i always play pont d4 as white
that's my counter counter gambit i think
that's a playable move actually
yeah it's not they take on d4 and then
you go
e5 i hope our opponent's not stream
sniping
it's okay it's not a good move so we'll
lead him astray
okay so this is the main line so um
taking on that f4 is playable
but i like to play the the pure gambit
and against someone who's not so well
prepared it's not so easy to develop for
white
uh with our pawn on e4 preventing that
f3
and then very often the bishop can come
to c5
yep
so this is actually the main line
uh bishop b4 and then there's a cool
idea coming up
if bishop d2 i have e3
deflecting the bishop and then basically
getting initiative for
a few moves
and the best pretty much the best part
is you're you're about to castle
and yeah as soon as the rook ends up on
e8
it's worth being down upon
especially like given that white has not
developed anything on the king side
yeah and we're already like getting the
open e file
um and there's a bunch of targets in the
position
i had a really cool trap like opening
trap from this
position oh except not this position
queen d2
i'll have to show you after this game
because there's a cool trap which can
emerge after bishop d
okay okay um
okay so i'm looking at queen e7
or just castling i think i'll just
castle
you just want that yeah that's a pretty
pretty permanent pin there
on c3 yeah like even
even if the king or queen move away i
mean it's going to be pinned to
something
looks like a solid okay we're gonna keep
applying the pressure
yeah positions like this you just want
to have as many
pieces applying pressure as possible
i'm a thing
okay we're gonna bring another piece
man so both knights are pinned okay now
this is usually where players are are
supposed to collapse like the
when there's like two major pins in a
position you should be able to often win
by tactics
yeah i'm looking for the
i mean okay there's a lot of like
forcing moves here
um not a lot of kos though
no no it still takes work i mean there's
lines where we
force b takes c3 and then we just attack
i think that's what i want to go for
and yeah for the time being the nylon e2
okay
as i say in the night and ichi was stuck
but now we can just win the exchange
i'm going to try and make i'm going to
try and not make the same mistake you
made in the previous game
which is management yourself too much
yeah yeah you can't enjoy yourself too
much in life
but it's you have a easier job because
your position
is like marginally better but not
so good that you can really enjoy it so
i that was my issues i got too good of a
advantage in the last game that's true
yeah it was just like you had so many
good options and then
and you're just paralyzed that was yeah
that was my fault
for that
um white's king moving
okay let's
and be aggressive oh did i blunder
oh i was enjoying myself too much
the good thing is you you never blunder
until the game's over if you end up
losing this game this will be a blunder
but if you end up winning it's exactly
yes that's true
yeah that's very true nice just giving
my
opponent a false sense of confidence
yep nice stack
okay so opposite color bishops
oh let's prevent the king from going
back
and then i'm preparing for some
beautiful meat i'm a big fan of that
white one connect four
yep there's only one thing let's go
beautiful
beautiful i'm gonna give that a ko
yeah everyone everyone watching on my
stream should check out chess bra stream
they have a cool kale graphic man
as a pond mate game one
so i mean if you guys are wondering what
kind of stream it's going to be
i think this is just an indication of
future energy
definitely so i'm trying to figure out
how to bring this game
into the analysis board
to show you this cool trap
yeah it's like i'm figuring it out are
you just grabbing the pgm
yeah should be able to drop it in okay i
think i did
i see that okay so um
i'll get i'll give it to you as a puzzle
but then chad can try and solve the
puzzle too
okay so this comes from a game it was
like over-the-board blitz game i played
years ago
um probably like 2011-ish
uh had this position um
[Music]
and here okay here our opponent play
queen d2 but the main move
is bishop d2 this is what i encountered
uh i took on c3 and this position might
play queen e2
check kind of inter meso
now it's black to move and find the way
to stay up material so we just took a
piece
white is obviously wanting to recapture
so it's black to move and basically
guarantee be up material um
but you also have to get out of check
yeah don't forget that we're gonna have
some dudes submitting bishop
takes b2 ah yeah
yeah in a tournament game that would be
unfortunate if you touch your bishop
and you'd be forced to play vision e5
yeah that would
that would be real bad
yeah some people in my chat have seen it
before i i've shown this maybe
once in a stress club lecture
my my chat has a 100
success rate wow um but we we had
someone suggest a
long time viewer of the channel
suggested castling here for black
oh dear so that's not actually a bad
thing like if you
if you touch your king and attempt to
castle
you can't legally castle but then you
would have to move your king
and then you would be more likely to
find the best move
so some guys you know would be like you
know debating between all these but the
guy who's just
castling he would grab the king he'd be
told by the arbiter hey dude
you can't be doing that and then he'd be
like oh man i have to move my king
and then as you said he's 200 iq
yeah it's still a one and two chance i
guess there's two legal king moves
but yeah good job to everyone in chat
finding
the very aesthetic king d7
the delayed reverse flipped bomb cloud
and yeah the whole idea is to just clear
the eight square it's basically a
clearance tactic
um
and yeah we get out of check and make a
threat so white doesn't have time to
take
because of this threat should note if
white so there's a few lines to show
of course if white takes here we um oops
we don't mouse slip we win the queen
if white takes here then we don't want
to play rook
at allowing bishop e5 so we take and
then
we win the queen in this line so what
happened in my game my opponent played
queen g4 check
after king d7 and then i played king c6
which is actually probably like the best
move and we just attack the
wait like our king now finds a safe
place and we attack the
queen with the bishop so again white
doesn't have time to take
and then we're just gonna be up a piece
yep so
it's not every day you can win material
in the opening
by developing your king especially this
line
it really emphasizes that you know the
last two moves king d7 king c6 winning
yeah probably the la you know move 10 to
see that on the notation sheet and maybe
white resigns after this would be
maybe one of the only games that you
could find like that right i think my
opponent tried like i tried to explain
my king
but um it turned out that white's king
was more of a target after queen f6
i'm just winning more material and my
king is just chilling
plays a crucial role in defending my
knight
it's fantastic
yeah so good memories yep but yeah this
is a fun line like
there's a lot of uh like nifty tricks
um i've like i
also went through a phase where i was
preparing this very deeply
and there's one really cool trap i'm
gonna try and remember
it's it's not really a trap it's just
like a cool idea
uh it comes from a main line this is one
of like the main lines like stronger
players will play
um hopefully i can remember it
so queen h4 g3
uh knight takes g3
and if you look this up in like the
database this is uh this is pretty
standard theory
uh queen e2 takes
um takes
i'm trying to remember
it's so interesting to me that we could
still have a trap
come from this it looks like yeah so the
main idea i forget exactly the main move
here i think it's bishop c4
i think it's some bishop move but i'll
just get to the point so the main
like cool idea is let's say light just
develops a bishop
black to move in wind material
it looks crazy because like white's
covering everything and um
we're we only have a bishop developed
but
it's just such a bizarre move it
actually reminds me of
um wasn't it i mean i'm pretty sure it
was like
wesley so had a bishop c1 from like
vikings a
one year um and it might have been
against report or it was reported
against wesley so it was one of the
other
um i'm pretty sure it involved uh
those guys but there's this like crazy
bishop c1 move and like maybe king's
indian or something
it was like it was like winning is like
the best move
[Music]
i just googled wesley so report bishop f
or bishop c1
here i'll look it up in the background i
just got a raid by the way from
another extremely eccentric and very
entertaining player mr joe bava so
thanks so much uh thanks so much bador
nice yeah i know he's he's been
streaming a lot lately and he also shows
like a bunch of tricky openings on his
stream
it's fun to watch yes without revealing
too many secrets i hope yeah
yeah i've seen him stream a lot more
recently so big shout out to uh
bad door for the raid there welcome
everybody just i'm just hanging out with
uh
mr i am rosen here and we're we're going
over
like some some crazy weird openings that
we like to play on our streams and
trying them out against the chat so i
actually found the
uh the wesley so game
um and maybe i can paste it in
but just to show this um
uh as we mentioned and good job to
people who were suggesting in chat
bishop c1
um and black is winning a pawn there's
no good way for white to defend b2
if like moves upon we trap the rook uh
i think this position is still like
relatively balanced
after knight d2 we win the pawn white's
gonna have some compensation
um but it's a cool idea and it goes
along with the spirit of this
uh this gambit line yep
so i'm pasting in i don't think i saw
this game
so closely but
um is this the moment or is it
yeah this one yeah exactly this is just
such a just a cool move an exact same
idea
it's like just a way to like either get
the bishop traded for the knight or
bring it around to d4
or like to a3 i just thought that this
bishop c1 was such a
shot in the dark in a position that
looks pretty pretty closed off
no it's the type of thing you would
almost never consider but it's nice you
take advantage of this knight d3 tactic
yeah
and like it's also really nice of queen
c2 here
we can still take on b2 because there's
still a fork
yes it's crazy yes
it actually reminds me um
last thing before we uh maybe get back
into another game i know i'm tangenting
here
but the um speaking of the you know the
london
they have the
i think the pretty classic trap
i think it's like this
i think it's um e5
and like bishop takes uh
c3 here and so this is kind of like how
black gets out of the opening
and you're kind of scrambling trying to
figure out what to do and it's like rook
b1 knight c4 and no matter what black
takes on b2 next move
and goes like knight c3 oh oh that's
dirty i actually haven't seen this one
before
oh yeah this is pretty much this is
pretty much
why i think this setup is a little
kind of suspicious against this so i
usually play knight c3 myself when i
when i see they're going to go g6 but
most london players especially when
they're starting out you know you just
want to play this triangle against
anything that comes at you so i think
it's pretty easy to get um
caught by this and i've had a number of
strong blitz players on just.com
catch me when i'm just like pre-moving
in a bullet game or something and i'm
like oh man i'm in this again
and it's just so hard to stop rookie 8
you kind of have to
get castle then and yeah it's bishop
that's actually really nice yeah no i
would imagine like white just played
kind of the natural
london setup yep um
but same idea as what we just looked at
where it's like this rogue bishop
basically can take everything in its
path
yeah it's incredible like white just
doesn't have resources to defend
yeah um anyway yeah i can uh get in
another game there
sounds good i like the uh i like the
post mortem as well
yeah no it's so easy to tangent
to like different uh uh different type
like
like you all show one idea that will
remind you like of another idea
i think this is uh
this is the case when when speaking to
like high-level chess players is
you just have like a whole knowledge
base of information
that's fun to share yep and uh
just to everyone i guess in both chats i
mean you guys can always keep the
challenges
coming in never hurts to have too many
or you know an assortment of ratings to
to choose from so i'm just gonna take
this one here
oh we got white again so this is uh this
is nice
let's see what d4 brings us this time
oh oh i have a tricky line against this
oh this is perfect
so you take it i don't know if you've
looked at this before
for the e6 and then knight c3
and then the idea is bishop takes c5
knight e4
that's one of my like favorite tricky
lines
if they play an f6 you play e4 and then
when they take on c5 you play e5
and then oh but they're not uh but he's
not to the degree of like
maybe not getting that pawn back yeah so
now you kind of have to improvise
you could be greedy here um i'll
probably leave it up to you but
so my
i have a lot of uh i have a few options
here
and i i generally don't pick the ones
that
look like bishop e3 because they're
they're too good the move is too good
so i'm gonna play knight b5 and see what
happens
wow leaving two pawns hanging
yeah like i would have played bishop e3
and then just tried to hold on to the
extra pawn and as you saw you know
although i was maybe chatting a little
bit more than
i'm used to in the first game that's the
risk of playing
a little bit too eccentric you know you
can just lose those games either you
take too much time or your position
actually
gets so bad or they play some good moves
and punish you for your
ambitions yeah no you have to be careful
okay bishop
did we takes bishop f4 or i was probably
planning on continuing the
sacrificial nature and hoping that he
wouldn't play
king e7 there perfect
i feel like this is one of those weird
sicilian variations but you're just down
[Music]
a tempo like your knight should be on c3
and not
g1 exactly
but that's okay and two bishops we got
dark squares for black
yeah tons of reasons to like this
position
well queen a3 is um it's nice we just
want to prevent
black from castling oh
i think we have to i think we have to
take yeah
we're going to take that for sure also
thank you
charlotte chess center with a raid hey
welcome people yeah so if you're just
joining
i know there's people trickling in maybe
in both chats
um but this is a a tricky opening
collaboration stream
with chess bra and we're we're trying to
play as many tricky openings as possible
trying to i guess share some secrets
yeah try not to give too much away but
um
i think both eric and myself have found
a lot of enjoyment
in chess lately through just kind of
experimenting and messing around with
openings so definitely
actually so these days i'm i don't
really hold back when it comes to
exposing secrets because i'm not really
a
competitive or serious player
um especially these days without really
any over-the-board tournaments
um so it's been nice to just like share
share everything i know
and then i'll learn more as a result oh
those nights are asking to be punished
yeah that's a little awkward it's
amazing how
poorly coordinated two nights so close
to one another can actually be
yeah like knights knights are not good
when they're like diagonal
one square or two squares from each
other
i gotta put those those bishops to work
yep this is a uh there's also a position
i'm
always looking at pawn storming on the
king side
yeah yeah even when queens are off the
board
that doesn't mean that you can't just
king side attack
just throw all the pawns on the rest of
the pieces i mean hey it helps to be up
a piece you know but
it helps to be up at peace
oh i like that rook lift so did he
apparently he wasn't
he wasn't trying to have any of it
knight b4
now he wants you to take the free pawn
i think i'm probably too attached to my
bishop
honestly what it might do is sack my
rook for the
the knight just to keep that bishop
at some it's a nice bit like the your
bishop on d6 is probably better than
most of
like all of box pieces combined
so let's nice do that quickly
and we'll just start advancing these
okay so i'll take that okay this time
you have to
deliver checkmate before you flag
is that the rule got it hopefully
oh see he knows how good my bishop is
man
oh man
i'm not falling for it again
no he's not taking my bishops i promise
you that
yeah you gotta promote to another bishop
yeah okay we were on the same page there
we go
i didn't even have to tell you that
oh oh i was gonna bring the other bishop
to a6
and go for rookie aid a nice little
that's funny we were totally
on the same page it wasn't i i basically
had it promoted and you were saying the
same thing
do you have auto queen turned on or you
do the like keyboard holding down i held
the the alt button
okay yeah that's the pro the pro
approach
oh believe me i've i've under promoted
my a good share of times
nice so i could
share maybe a few tidbits about this
line
yeah it's basically i think it's called
the benoni gambit accepted
going back to analysis board
um
yeah a lot of players just don't know
how to deal with this like a lot of
people play
um they'll first take they'll run into
knight e4
they'll play bishop e7 and then you just
enjoy life
i've had this countless countless times
in blitz
there is kind of a more nifty way for
black to play
so there's two moves that people will
play here
uh is knight f6 and d5
those are those are pro moves yeah where
you like black allows
knight takes bishop and then queen a5 to
win back the piece
um i'll say that knight f6 is
objectively the best move
and then it's like close to equality in
both lines you got the bishop here
um but after d5 a lot of players will at
least good players
will start thinking here and then play
d5
and then there's like a cool idea for
white uh
engine approved it's actually engine's
top choices after takes
black wins back the piece and then
there's a really nice move for white
that that goes in the spirit of the
position is e4
it's not even like a pawn sacrifice
um because after black takes you have
queen g4
yes and then like you're opening the
position you have the two bishops you're
getting very quick
initiative and development looks great
yeah i guess black could defend with
queen e5 but then you just keep
developing and it's a fun position
that's usually the best part when they
they try to keep the pawn
exactly yeah and then there's some like
i guess there's some more concrete ideas
like if queen six you can take
and then bishop b5 and take away box
castling rights
and then went back the pawn and um
yeah so there's like much deeper
preparation you can do beyond
just this like kind of cool ideon move
three
um and yeah it's great because most
people like most
black players who play c5 usually run
into d5
yeah this is a pretty rare move already
i would say so like or at least if it's
if it's ever played whoever's playing
with the black pieces probably has the
confidence like
oh this is not a good move i just take
back i have the center
yeah yeah um not realizing like whites
white has tricks and then i've had a lot
of games after knight f6
and then bishop takes c5 where we just
start punishing black
because then the knight has no good
squares but to go back to
yeah let me play g8 combination of
knight e4 queen g4 and
it's so much fun oof
so that's my um
yeah that's my little uh pat line with
pawn c5
i like it yeah and it's nice that
there's not too many options
like it's not a ton to remember in terms
of every position
kind of has the same structure yeah i
know it's really simple like
because after it takes like you're
pretty much guaranteed to get this and
then
um or like what happened in our game you
get an e4
i guess we can you kind of improvised
with with this yeah i don't think i
don't think you're supposed to play b5
that's for damn sure
yeah so actually um this is this
approach from black it's interesting
objectively it's dubious and i know you
didn't want to play like the
the civil move here bishop e3
but there is a nice idea here after
queen a5
um
i was using i thought there was some a3
move
but maybe i was checking the engine line
maybe this isn't anything special
to play b4 eventually
yeah maybe this doesn't quite work
because b4 there's knight c3
it gets a little bit murky so this would
probably take like further
analysis exactly like maybe just bishop
d3 and we
we play chess just play normal but but
from black's point of view you're
you're kind of in a more comfortable
position than anything like allowing
pawn e5
or any of that stuff that's true yeah
that's very true
um yeah so there's there's always
drawbacks to sometimes playing these
these weird lines but um anyway
fun game yep i can go ahead
and yep i'm following still okay a lot
more people challenging me
so i uh people can use the chest
challenge command in my chats
um i'm gonna play the first person who
sent the challenge from
long ago bazman
i'm white i'll play e4 he's from the
netherlands there's like michael bassman
right is the
the the guy from the netherlands who's
pretty well-known
as well for playing some quite eccentric
stuff
i'm not too well versed in uh in pop
culture but
maybe yeah i i recognize the name like
b-a-s-m-a-n i'm pretty sure it's like
that or
or maybe it's emmanuel bazboom or
something like that there's there's
definitely a quite a famous dutch guy
who who also i played with him
once in a like a rapid tournament and
uh and he was you know type of guy that
was playing chess um as if he'd had
multiple beers and he was also having
the multiple beers
interesting oh
so it kind of hides it you feel that you
feel like it shouldn't yeah you feel
like he's
you know like he's kind of blundering
and playing lackadaisically he's
actually totally like
in control and that's how you would play
normally so interesting false sense of
security
so uh alejandro did that to me once
the first time i ever played alejandro
ramirez was like this world open blitz
tournament
he like stumbled into the playing hall
had like a
i think a glass of wine from the bar and
then he just whipped out like some
nasty opening trap and he was completely
like in the zone of like playing good
chess
yeah and like i completely
underestimated him
um okay so we're actually we're playing
online
i recently covered this in a youtube
video
i was i was sharing this or sharing my
preparation to another streamer
uh kimmy liu because she was saying how
like she plays a grand prix
but like this idea with e6 and d5 is
really annoying
um oh black's not going into
hoping for but okay so with this this is
a bit more positional
i'm wondering if we can make it can make
it more tricky
[Music]
i'm going to play i'm going to be civil
here i'm gonna follow my style and just
share
like a nice sort of positional idea when
the black pawns are doubled on the c
file
yep um like usually in the grand prix
white wants to attack on the
king side but in this position
there's a positional idea knight a4 a b3
c4
where we just like try and massage the
queen side pawns
it's funny he's actually chosen a
variation with knight e7 it works
terribly against what you just outlined
yeah so black like black has to be very
careful not to just get dominated by um
by positional play um so 97 was actually
the main line instead of a6
wow jeez oh i just want to play some
nine on f6
oh man drop knight at f6 if this were
bug house i'd be stalling
uh i'm so tempted to now just go crazy
listen to your heart okay f5
it's a typical grand prix like sacrifice
but it's funny that maybe you wouldn't
have played it last move
but now that he's defended the square
more times you'll play it
yeah because there's just more potential
for files to open
[Music]
looking for
i could leave the time okay let's take
once here
so we could see a similar theme
[Music]
from
uh the previous game i think this king's
gambit game where
we were castled black's underdeveloped
on the king sign
the black king is going to be in the
center for
is maybe the rest of the game
[Music]
oh
could take with knight though let's take
with rook i think this this actually
wins more material
i think you do this even if there was no
bishop on g7
definitely yeah the the more annoying
move to see as black because after the
knights on e6
he can't castle in either direction it's
like terrible i'll admit i didn't see
bishop d4
but i guess we're getting something kind
of uh
similar anyway yep debating bishop e3
let's keep our bishop
i still think this is great
maybe that shows how low my standards
are
so with the nylon e6 it just controls so
many squares in black's territory
and prevents black from castling either
way
um the queen is likely to move and then
probably queen e2 is coming next
bishop f4 incoming
that's a good move i really want to keep
this knight here
okay let's turn the fork
sure
that was probably a bad move but
okay this looks fun yeah you'd rather
keep the pieces on
this is definitely a w yeah
yeah sometimes bad decisions lead to
better stories
yeah what was this yeah so black kind of
suffered with kind of being behind the
development and
um probably was objectively typically
better
but yeah it's difficult to play after
especially after the e-file opens
yep yeah he's not castling
safely anytime soon that's for sure
yeah like there's too many too many ways
we basically develop and attack
at the same time the 97 pawn and d5
so i can quickly show just like one one
more tidbit of opening prep
um maybe absolutely back on
[Music]
yeah um
so this is a more specific line um i
guess
it's it's nice for anyone who plays like
knight c3 sicilian
or plays grand prix um
and with this specific position uh
the main line here is 97.
um should note if d4 d4 is a positional
mistake because then we take and
we get like just a very nice kind of
center structure
and black spawns are weak um
so 97 would be an attempt to avoid
uh bishop take c6 and avoid the double
pawns
so here we can take
once on d5 if knight takes e5 we double
box pawns
so pawn digs e5 then here there's a nice
positional move queen e2
and we pin the knight we're threatening
again positional play with taking
and it's not so easy for black to like
cover everything
um and a lot of natural moves for black
just don't work
like bishop d7 breaking the pin hangs
this pawn
g6 allows queen e5
bishop e6 attempting to break the pin
we still take and black can't take with
knight because f5
so there's just a lot of like annoying
things black has to worry about
um it's nice like we're more developed
anyway in blacks
both of black's developed pieces are
pinned
and the queen often goes to e2 in this
line so it's not like you're making some
weird concession
exactly
so yeah i first saw this line years ago
there's a book on grand prix by gawain
jones
and he covered this pretty in depth
i i mean a grand prix attack is it's a
very very tricky opening
it's not like a it's not an opening that
has a clear answer to it
yeah no there and there's a lot of like
um
choices for white too in in these
various lines
even against e6 like you could you could
play g3
you could play close sicilian you can
then later transpose into open sicilian
so i play this in like high level
tournament play
especially against players who maybe
play something different against knight
c3 than they're doing it's like f3
because there's always a possibility of
transposing into open sicilian
yes of course so flexible
yeah and then there's this like this new
kind of line like after d6
i think this carlson inspired line d4
and then like going for this like b3
bishop b2 setup
yeah this has become quite popular
recently
i'm a fan yeah but then against like
lower
rated players i just love grand prix and
like in general
because a lot of players will just get
like brutally attacked on the king's
side
um f5 is so strong the the problem is
like
even if you play f5 when it's not a good
move
it's still probably a good move or it'll
still work out can still usually make it
work for like blitzer bullets like it's
just more fun to
play with attack yeah there's a typical
line i think here
like this is a very like well-known
position where
after e takes f5 black's pretty much
lost
due to queen h4 and like the attack is
so so strong
like this idea there's just yeah you're
not surprised
so yeah as black if you play sicilian
you have to
know something against uh against grand
prix
yeah the grand prix especially like as
you're starting out i mean the
percentage of people that play it
against the sicilian i think it would be
like super high
yeah i've noticed that like a lot of
like
just in general it seems like more
people these days are playing
anti-sicilians than the the classic like
open sicilian
which maybe makes sense like white is
keeping the game in their
their territory and not giving black so
many options
i think that because the computers have
become so
strong it maybe makes more and more
sense to
get a position that you know better than
your opponent
not that your computer knows better than
theirs
that's very true yeah and this is
sometimes the problem with like these
theoretical
like open sicilian lines is like they're
so concrete and i can come down to
computer preparation
all right well let me get another game
in here another
another unsuspecting uh chap
okay we're gonna go for it with a guy
from finland i'm getting white every
game these are great you know
shout out to chess.com on these this is
perfect
treat every game like uh like a brand
new 50 50 coin flip
is that how they do it is just 50 50
because then
i have no idea but if that was the case
then it looks like i'm winning every
coin flip
do you have any like tricky lines
against carol khan
so i basically the character like
especially this
um this c6 d5 and whenever i get to go
knight c3 knight f3 um
i i usually end up with like a pretty
decisive attack
in this line so i've never really felt
compelled to
search for something because the
traditional positions are often so
crushing
at least in my experience interesting
yeah i know it's it's an easy line to
play i was going to say this line
specifically a lot of players will play
bishop f5 instead of h6
and then there's like there's a really
cool trappy line that a lot of amateurs
will fall into
yeah i i think i get that one a fair bit
and then if they don't do that i mean
for example h6 here is like
definitely making me think about all
sorts of 95 queen h5 stuff
so now now he goes bishop there which is
uh
quite intelligent intelligent
i'm definitely uh okay i'm definitely
going to start with
the only reasonable move any sane humans
yeah
for a moment i was thinking maybe you
could jerome like bishop f7 knight e5
queen h5 but this is
i think the the problem with that is you
you hand the initiative over to him
after king e6 and suddenly he's the one
practicing
yeah yeah
i mean you and i witnessed the the power
of the white king
you know reaching the middle of the
board earlier on in our our stream so
that's very true i can't be handing that
out too easily you know
man he didn't take your free knight he's
he's an amateur queen said he's an
amateur player yeah
okay to go well gotta be careful not to
like
hang every single piece to queen d4 next
move or something
oh that's true oh wow that's like a
triple
man it is a triple but i'm gonna play
queen f3
in in anticipation of queen d4
i mean queen d4 is kind of kind of hard
to refuse
yeah i'll admit like
when i first saw position after e6 like
i would have played queen f3 instantly
without even thinking but queen d4
wow
as you said you know sometimes sometimes
you got to make some questionable
decisions to end up
on the desired path
okay queen yeah our opponent's playing
very uh very safe
very safe h6 e6 queen c7
so i'm just easy to crack finally get
some space here with d4
i am curious after queen d4 where you
you were planning not f7
right so i was planning to go knight f7
to which i think he only has one
reasonable response
which would be bishop takes e4
and you know i obviously don't want to
reveal
my you know my prep after that yeah i
don't want to let everyone know
obviously okay um
i'm gonna
can't go to f3 again
okay here definitely thinking of
just castling offering
that yeah
i would have played bishop f4 there but
i i like the pawn sack
well i'm also kind of hoping that i'm
more innocuous from
the starting rank to play bishop takes
h6 like it's more unsuspecting
if i play bishop f4 i don't know my
bishop's already out my king's in the
middle
okay
and now it's like i i got that pawn sack
in except
he's missing an h pawn somehow
yeah i bet he regrets playing h6
so long ago wow he regretted so much he
wanted to get another pawn to h6
yeah if he doesn't have a pawn there
what is he without his pawn
okay let's take this and it looks kind
of hard to stop me here
honestly i see a few moves but
no when you have a white pawn on f6
against the castle king
especially if you're not down material
yeah like usually you sack a lot of
things to make this happen
i like that move yeah you prevent
box queen from really helping out
yeah i definitely don't want to deal
with um queen h3 or queen h5 and then
queen f4 or something like that
queen g3 would be the the oops so let's
grab this handle mercy
well the the only problem about this
position is that my opponent has a
couple seconds because
that this is the type of position where
i could pretty much work as straight up
pawn checkmate if i wanted to
because yeah i mean i'm in full control
here right like there's so many
oh that's that's so cruel yeah no this
is my
this is my specialty you know you just
can butcher someone real badly yeah if
they continue to play i mean
they're in trouble i mean your rook was
kind of like lonely on a1 the whole game
so at least you gave it some purpose in
life
so now if someone tunes in to the stream
you know maybe some new viewers what's
up everyone
as you can see grand master always make
sure all his pieces
are working you know everyone's part of
the attack here
and that's why my opponent lost this
game
yeah a smooth game i feel like that was
one of your smoothest schemes
yet of this uh this stream
yeah i i'm just a big fan of
knight c3 knife that's like always what
i tell people
if anyone's like hey what do i do
against the chirok coward con is a
really solid opening honestly
um but this two night variation pretty
much means that you get
like kind of the bare minimum is you get
two bishops in a
really comfortable game and you know
anything other than that
is you know anywhere from a 10 move win
to
you know a queen sack for mate so i i
think it has a very high ceiling
and it's not like it has a floor either
it's not like you're
risking a terrible position so it's just
like a i find it super comfy
i completely agree yeah no this is like
this is what i recommend
for for e4 players who want something
against caro khan i think it's very
effective
at the lower levels even at the higher
levels too
yeah absolutely and it's it's definitely
counterintuitive to to enter
some of the like some of the lines that
are kind of recommended for black here
i think are really counter-intuitive to
to play so you won't see them too much
you'll see exactly i think the most
common one is what you and i were both
mentioning which was like taking on
on e4 and bishop f5
and playing it as if there was a pawn on
d4 and just not noticing that there's a
significant difference so it's
incredible like so many carol khan
players
who are maybe new to the opening or
lesser experience will walk into this
line
it's incredible how big how bad bishop
f5 is for black
yeah you really have to be to be
conscious of
of exactly what could happen to you yeah
because i assume that this is the line
you're referring to
exactly yep um bishop h7
and it keeps getting worse for black
yeah either bishop or
so queen h5 i i recommend first oh
because then there's a potential for
like this oh no my queen moment
yes yeah you want to play c4 as quickly
as possible
make it seem yeah what i usually do is i
pre-move it
that's the best way to do it um so if
you pre-move queen here the nice thing
is there's
there's nothing that black could really
do except bishop g6
and the likelihood of him doing that is
pretty low because he just moved it away
so if he goes like
knight f6 and blunders mate and you
accidentally pre-moved this then
you know it's even better it's like you
know what an idiot and then you get him
anyway
so that's the best way to do it yeah and
then the like the other way to defend f7
is queen d5
which then bishops e4 is just winning
tactic
yeah and then after uh
after g6 of course we threatened mate
and then black pretty much so this is
all pretty much
like the most expected line
starting when black played bishop f5
yep like black is subjecting himself to
just such
misery and bishop is the only devout
piece now caged in
and now what move do you play here
uh queen f3 oh so i play queen e2
queenie two i think is slightly slightly
trickier because you're threatening
obviously queen f3 you're threatening
maiden one but queenie two you're
threatening knight takes f7
and all the natural moves for black so
bishop here
uh knight d7 bishop d6 knight f6 they
all are blunders because of knight f7
yep so black has to play like one more
awkward move to defend against the
threat so if
if here then this is mating
um so yeah this is such a great line
and then queen is it queen c7 that they
have to some sort of weird queen so
queen yeah queen c7 queen e7 i mean
queen c7 there's probably d4 bishop f4
coming yeah so uh
yeah and the goal is to get castle queen
side and
bring the rook to e1 and basically the
guy's gonna be mated sometime
soon definitely yeah
i can't tell you like how many people
i've i've trapped in this like over the
years
and i've shown this to students who go
on to trap players too
so it's uh that's a nice line
yeah so that was that was a smooth one
and he didn't really go into
any of this stuff but as we saw he sort
of was playing very timidly
in general and like all all i really did
was
pieces to the the squares that were kind
of talking about in this game as well
and
d4 like nothing nothing too special that
the pieces i find really flow in this
opening is quite nice
right so i'm just having a suppressed
memory
i i should bring up um i remember
watching peters fiddler
play this as white and he played like a
new idea i had never seen before and i i
didn't really check it afterwards
but new idea is black or white so as
white
uh it was just like a one of these like
banter blitz sessions he played queen f3
um obviously threatening mate
and after knight f6 you play queen b3 i
think this is another like fine approach
for white
um i probably prefer this
this queen h5 line but this just wins a
clean pawn
so you say it wins
a clean pawn but um i'm imagining that
after
queen here um if knight f6
you go queen v3 and you're kind of happy
and the great thing is that
um let's say queen d5 like the thing
that i like for black
is that if you go queen takes b7
queen takes e5 is that you know you can
dream of like trapping the queen
with queen c7 and even that just being
in the position
kind of kind of scares me a little bit
as white like having my queen
in the corner like that but oftentimes
what people do is they
are waiting for this to happen and
they'll blender mate
or something that's like yeah this uh
this england gambit style mates
you know so they'll like defend their
night or it's some something to like
prepare this and just
walk into that's from me
yeah it reminds me of the whatever that
queen's
gambit line is that kind of goes like
this i think
i don't think i've seen this one before
um yeah i'm pretty sure it's like
this and
some sort of like knight h4 bishop here
and you oh yeah you end up threatening
oh that's so
nice oh wow wow you end up threatening
knight g6 like i haven't seen obviously
before they're crippled with f takes and
then you're threatening this queen c8
which we'll get the beep on as well
wow soy's just better here yeah so
this is just yeah and this it's just
very like
um it preys on the people who have no
clue you could ever be threatening queen
h3
so you play queen b3 and they they have
the option to play queen c7 let's say
but
everyone is gonna play queen b6 because
it's just sort of more natural
and you don't have your bishop on f4
which is usually the indicator that
queen b6 is safe
yeah i'm actually curious like because
this is kind of a common opening for
black i guess the weird
move is knight d2 yeah i think i might
be
like giving it away too early i was just
i knew that this was part of it so
when i was trying to think of it right
now i played this first but i'm pretty
sure
you would kind of go there and then they
would go here and you go knight d2
and to them it's like oh this is a free
bishop f5 there's no bishop f4
i get e6 next like the black player is
going to be very interested in
getting their bishop out and they won't
go bishop g4 because 95
right is you're not pinned yet so
they'll all go here
and then from here you can't start with
queen b3 because
it could take so you have to start with
the knight and
again they know they're gonna like end
up giving you free pawn moves here and
bishop back is never enticing so it's
pretty common they just
draw back and try to go for that solid
thing and the likelihood at this point
when you're this deep in the line that
you get it is nearly 100.
that's awesome yeah that's really nice
so this reminds me of something
completely ridiculous
but i figure i'll show it because it's
kind of it's a nice party trick
um imagine
you know that your opponent will copy
all of your moves
so your opponent just plays copy catch
us
you can win in three moves
by doing this garbage
so just a cool party like if you're ever
gonna like play a friend and like
who's new to chess and they say they're
going to copy your moves
you can uh yeah can win like this that's
a good one because i have this rule that
i like to repeat
that generally players who are rated
under 1000
don't have a vision range longer than
about three squares
so there's no way they would see bishop
takes h3 so you're you're totally safe
playing this move and they would
definitely
cut it's not like they would stop
copying and be like ah hang on
i'm not falling for that and they take
the queen so no worries there that's
good
i like that yeah no it takes it takes
time to develop like
full board vision
and then there's another even more
garbage uh c4 c5
and then this is another three or
whatever
how maybe four moves uh
these are great yeah these are perfect
for parties because at least
the kind of parties i might have there's
often people that have no clue about
chess and of course
they're asking all these questions so
it's like yeah you sit them down and you
give them false hope
yeah you know i'm really really good at
this game i'm a professional just
copy my moves and just bait them in
yeah no this is uh that's it's nice
all right i'm gonna uh i'm
probably gonna find another victim
yeah i'm just gonna go in order uh
edvards
and foreign ff are we going to keep up
our whites
oh we're not okay so i'm black okay so
trappy repertoire involves pre-moving e5
i definitely agree um oh
how familiar are you with the stafford
gambit uh
i would say like um honestly speaking
i'm going to say unfamiliar like
i sort of know the basic moves and like
i watched a video for example but
overall i would say unfamiliar okay i'm
scared
my opponent's playing really quickly so
i assume
uh is probably like knows what to do
um you've seen a video or two yeah no
he's playing so there is this pog champs
match
between uh hafu and david pakman
and hafu was prepared i think by robert
hess
and like she she whipped this out and um
it was like a really nice opening
as white or black as white and david was
like he played the stafford i think
inspired by me
um so and and uh nier ditzki did a whole
breakdown of like how to refute the
stafford
and he showed he showed this as a
recommendation for whites
so the what's your stance on the
let's say the refutations that might be
out there like does it make it
unplayable to a degree or is it still a
position you can like
it's still you can kind of work with
okay um that's good like white has to be
really really really well prepared
but almost no one is um
like people will know c3 but they won't
know um beyond actually this is a new
move for me
because most people play d4 here yeah um
yeah i think debating bishop
and there's also like weird move queen
h4 here
um but generally the compensation
when they do trade on g4 is to leverage
this
uh this half open each file i like it
um i'll have a lot of things to show
like after this game
[Music]
um because after neroditsky made like
this refutation video
jonathan tronce came out with a video
where he
drew stockfish like the highest level of
stockfish
in this exact line in the line that
naradiski recommends
damn and um i i think like he did a lot
of preparation with like leela
um but it was like such a cool variation
and that's what
i kind of tried picking up
um i explored myself a bit the thing i
i like about some of the openings that i
play is that
um nobody can really release a video
refuting them because
i mean in essence they are they are
refuted
as soon as i play it it's like you know
the eval is so bad and it's not like any
specific line
is worse for me than any other one so
that's kind of sad
[Music]
so white's playing actually very solidly
and this is sometimes what will happen
is
like white will play solid stuff and
then we're kind of forced to
go insane but that's what makes life
this happens
that that's kind of the uh the
entire lifespan of an opening like this
is
it's really fun at the beginning and
then you get people posting videos
refuting it
and people like yeah but there's so many
more layers to unpeel
like honestly when i saw this nirajitsky
video i thought stafford's just dead
like he was so thorough
and then jonathan just came out with
this magic trick
wow i want to play f4
when in doubt on poisson
also uh jonathan insurance is in my chat
shout out to vampire chicken
hey yeah i've seen him uh on twitch and
more importantly on youtube where i mean
if you're like interested in
kind of random super fun openings that
are presented
in a very matter-of-fact way um
jonathan's youtube is is like kind of
the og
full of them no he's very much like a
trendsetter like
the ortho schnapp and ackmanson i think
he recently came out with a course on
the nagmanson
adjustable one yeah yeah i think i saw
that as well
okay i'm i'm finding ways to have fun
just gonna like keep pushing pawns and
take
everything
[Music]
an important decision
so wait what's the material oh i'm just
up a rook
and i have the bishop here
but white wants a castle
okay let's castle before white castles
nice thing about losing pawns is you
open files
this is correct
man i don't know if i can live up to to
your
ability to promote to another well
you're the only one with a pawn track
made in this stream so
that's true oh more than holding up
can i get another pawn checkmate yeah i
was gonna say if he had more time
oh can i get that oh no i can't
i wanted to set up on poisson checkmates
i think you just win at that point yeah
okay oh that was gonna be a pawn
checkmate right like one more move
that's upon me
oh yeah i actually didn't oh on the same
square as previously
two yep i mean that's just unlucky
that's
that's a pawn checkmate and a half i'll
give you yeah
okay yeah i could spend hours talking
about stafford gambits but
uh can at least cover the what happened
in this game
um pace of pgn
yeah so i've like i recently realized
i can just have a repertoire where i
pre-move e5 on move one
and whatever white plays
i'll i'll have some preparation
so like d4 you play the england e4
obviously
like go into hopefully sapphire gambit
if knight f3
this is called the walrus
and if takes you play knight c6
um it's objectively bad but it's
it's a walrus so it's fun um and if
tapes
it has a name then you know yeah
basically animal name
after e4 does it transpose to the
staffers yeah i was gonna say e4
it's just a direct transposition okay so
that's probably the best part of it
yeah yeah it's like the main reason to
play the walrus
and if they play um d4
e5 the nice thing is that if you don't
feel like playing
the uh england you can always play
whatever this is called oh i was going
to show this to you but you've seen it
already
yeah okay yeah we're on
we're on the same page here this is all
i ever do these days
in addition just saffron but you have
you have to pre-move 97
yes and then you got to play with this
if they play bishop f4
uh you've pre-moved 97 and then you
pre-move knight c6 here
yeah the first time i ever had this in
the live stream was against jonathan
trance
and he he walked into us he uh yeah he
took that i i think i saw
derek get like narratives yeah
yeah that that was like the clip i saw
yeah no i've had this
probably five or six times on stream
um it's fun because you like it looks
like complete garbage it looks like
you're just pre-moving
nonsense and then you win their queen
yep anyhow continue so okay so stafford
gambit
uh opponent was probably like clearly
prepared here
because played then moves instantly um
i mean there's so many traps uh just to
start with like if bishop g5 this loses
to 94
you say oh no my queen and then you mate
so i get tweets almost on like a
these days it's probably a weekly basis
of people like sending me their games
from this position
um another trap if knight c3 actually
hikaru
walked into this as white in one of his
like gambit speed runs
this just walks into knight g4 and
blocks battery right
bishop e3 we take and we we're happy
um then there's some other cool lines
like if white tries to be really really
safe in place h3
we we take on f2
and then this is just a fun line like
it's fun to analyze
um the engine the engine will give
castling here and it's just like equal
a white's king could like take and um
the engine says equal find some
perpetual
but i can blitz her bullet we just play
this for a win
yeah yeah of course always playing for a
win
it's it's funny like move nine white's
only develop piece is a king on e4
and yeah why not get all the way to the
center if you're going to commit that
much
yeah and then similar line like if i
play c3 here
um in this line we take on e4 first
hit f2 because if takes we win the queen
and if queen e2 we take and then
uh play f5
um f5 king c2 and then castle and
like we're going to lose a piece but
it's a it's a fun position
so yeah um yeah i have a lot of like
expensive crap in a lot of these lines
but
yeah so this bishop e2 line see it seems
like he chose one
that somebody who had either seen a
video or
had something bad happen to them in this
language play right right yeah
a lot of people like will maybe see this
first and then walk into one of the
traps
so actually my most viewed video on
youtube
uh it's called beating everyone with the
same opening trap
and it features this position like three
games i had in the same day
yeah or after castling knight g4
uh h3 and then queen d6
yes this this to me is like um
the essence of the staffer i don't know
if that's true and maybe things have
changed but this position is i think of
the staffer one
i think definitely no the like there's a
lot of similar lines where like these
same ideas apply
where you uh yeah you use your rook pawn
the knight the bishop the queen
um it's funny like how many people play
g3 here and then just get mated
um yeah i mean what else so the blade
only has one move not to lose
which is kind of hard to find i'll just
go ahead and show it as e5
and it it works because if you take with
the queen then
then bishop takes and there's rookie one
um but after e5 it's playable like you
win back your pawn
and it's a game actually in some cases
you're still wanting to go back yeah i
was gonna say you might just return
yeah so there's still venom so anyway
our opponent played
this nerdetsky recommendation um
[Music]
i like i like that you know just yeah
the snare it is key recommendation
this is trashy yeah no it's um
like he he went really like it's a half
hour video like breaking down like
everything that can do and
how to punish every every line so in
in his video he covers mainly bishop b6
which is what i was actually
like this was still kind of my prep uh
before i saw
jonathan trance's video where like
you're
you're discouraging white to play d4
because then you win the e4 pawn
um and if castling then you still have
these ideas
um the problem is after knight d2
it's really hard to find active play for
black
yeah i mean the issue looks like knight
c4 is just happening
you flew as that bishop you kind of lose
everything right
yeah so um so this is where jonathan
tron says prep comes in
where like he amazingly just like if you
turn on sockfish it'll say
plus like three and
he found a way to get a position which
even stockfish doesn't understand
uh and after d4 best move
queen h4 yep
threatening me this is actually what i
thought i can't castle
so g3 and then queen f6
threading mate or not mate yeah this
isn't mate but
we want to win f2 um
most natural move for white appears to
be f3
at this point stockfish says plus five
there's a lot of things hanging yeah um
knight and bishop are hanging and
objectively like it's pr
it's probably losing for black somehow
in one of these lines but h4 yeah like
we just leave the pieces hanging
and i don't remember the full game but i
can encourage people to look up
the jonathan trance video because i know
it took him
probably hours and hours of prep
to actually find a line that works
against stockfish
um and there is some really really cool
idea in the
video too involving i think after
rook g1 we
take we take and play like rook h2
i'm not remembering though so people
will have to check out the video
yeah you have to check the video
okay h2 dc5 and then some like bishop
bishop e6 i think it's actually this
line
and then queen d4 is it this and then
bishop c4
i think it's this line actually that he
had because i
i have stockfish turned on and like it
said plus five but now it's only saying
like plus three
so it's super cool like bishop c4 like
comes out of nowhere
wow and like bishop can be taken with
two different things
if if queen takes knight e5
and like blocks down two pieces
but has monster initiative
if queen takes queen we take we actually
just made in two
yep and then if um
[Music]
if bishop takes we take on actually
95 is still strongest and white's
getting forked
somehow wow
so there's like a lot of unexplored
territory in these lines which uh
still has room for development so cool
anyway so that's uh i don't think i've
formally shown this
on stream yet like the
response to nerditsuki's video but uh
right it's um yeah software gambit i
think is still alive even against strong
players
that's cool that's good that's
reassuring yeah
oh i can show one more actually there's
one more
[Music]
so there's another move here h3
makes a lot of sense honestly yeah like
just preventing and it seems like okay
all of black's counterplay is stopped
because you can't play knight g4
but um i'll give some backstory this is
uh
this is what carlson played against
stafford gambit he's encountered it
twice in online games
and he played h3 and then
his opponent played actually the best
move though really the only move to
still stir up counter play is queen d4
and then carlson here just played the
bad move and then black was uh was doing
completely fine
he just also played bishop e3 and then
after this
block's completely fine sure and
probably objectively better because
after this
this this there's a nice idea a queen
here
and eventually like this stuff
so like if i were to play carlson
and had the chance to play stafford i
would hoping he repeats this line
and then if he if if white plays the
best move here castling
um white has to walk a really really
thin tightrope to not lose
and we play queen d6 and again we have
this
this threat i was going to say they're
they're about to get re-stafforded
yeah like this is the exact same thing
as as before basically
someone is asking in my chat why am i
showing this
yeah i guess i'm revealing some secrets
but i mean it's it's so
deep and elaborate that i can't show
everything but
um i mean the main idea is after c3
knight g4 and
like the the fun continues yep same
stuff
and the only move that doesn't lose for
white is e5
and so we're kind of harder to find that
a bullet game
but uh the e5 is is kind of annoying
but then there's some line like we can
take on f2 and
like still try and fight like takes
takes and
gets some end game rook for two pieces
if that's the the worst you know
considering all the upsides here
not not that bad yeah like
and then like you're probably guaranteed
the time advantage if
if you know this uh if you haven't
memorized and
um yeah definitely not bad for bullets
so anyway um yeah i i could spend
many more hours but uh yeah save some of
the secrets
to keep something secret yeah yeah yeah
because you still wanted to you still
want to get those positions
that's true yeah i mean my logic is
that um i mean
i put more more time than most people
that even if people
know know some lines i'll hopefully know
them better
so uh-huh agreed
um so here i'll take maybe one of the
higher highest rated guys challenging
right now
1600 a few challenges this is good
disappeared so let's do this one
man i'm just rolling the whites today
maybe everyone
took black like as part of their
challenge i'm not sure
i'm not sure oh this one again ha
well i mean i think so you know you
could do you could play e4
and play a smith mora it's just another
like
but up to you well the thing is he's
definitely watching so i feel like he's
ready
for dtc5 so it's definitely you know you
definitely don't give people what
they're
what they want yeah you know
we want to be in control here
yeah smith mora is like a danger
especially when they accept
the smithmore is very dangerous i i
don't know what this is called but
oh like the danish inspired yeah
one more one more and in this position
you know
i'm pretty sure it's to some people's
liking to go queen b3 and hope they take
on a1 but the problem is they can take
on c1
you know i mean in general you can't
complain about
three extra moves of development
yeah and three open files for whites
like you said you start hanging pawns or
losing them or trading them
it just opens everything up yeah
oh mark asterman would be proud
seeing some sermon emotes
so i wonder what the
what the prescribed uh
medication is here yeah there's some
cases in the mora
where like you don't really try and bite
them immediately you just
kind of put your pieces on good squares
and
let them suffer trying to develop
exactly
start with a with a rook i think there's
probably no position where it
doesn't belong here okay
so we're going to bite them immediately
or at least we're going to invite the
bike oh
yeah this is a very thematic move
honestly i would have played like queen
e2 rook d1
yeah threading e5 exactly
i guess we're trying to get this classic
situation where we have the open e file
and lock's not castled
like we've already had that in a few
games so far
so my plan was like takes takes 95
to take it and give this bishop b5 check
and try to push d6
and he's having none of the above
so i think the good thing here is like i
just
probably take the dark squirt bishop and
try to be satisfied with that go like
queen d2 rook d1 and
probably like queen g5 at some point
i like it yeah no this dark straight
bishop especially
because now black doesn't have a bishop
to contest it
that'll be with tempo
that'll be with tempo too i'll give him
that
okay
okay i was thinking for a moment bishop
d5
but yeah me too i don't know
black doesn't need to take it exactly
exactly
e5 i've seen quite nearly works
i'm getting the feeling that it doesn't
i'm going to uh
stick with the mo i like it
yeah i think with the bishops they just
kind of sit there they apply pressure
and then you just have to
bring in some more weapons yep
and then like mathematically you're
going to have more attackers than black
house defenders hopefully
i hope so i hope so
okay so i'm just going to throw that
there
now i'll never get mated that's all i
can tell myself
i can feel good about that
all you have to do is not get mated and
not get flagged
yes the nice thing about knight a5 is
it's going to provoke this
questionable move i like it
wait this is actually looking and you
got
your your e-file i i got what i want
got the pressure
but can you orchestrate a pawn mate
that's the
real issue my h-pawn is the closest uh
closest thing i have okay it's gotta be
with the rook
i'm not sure that really helped him out
here though yeah i was expecting queen
f8
but nobody is
it's actually like it was the bishop
on v2 that kind of was the thing that
annoyed black the
the entire game um and pretty much
secured the win
i think that when you're dealing with
this line i know it's
i know it's maybe counter-intuitive but
i'm sure that the
light squared bishop is the lesser of
two evils so i might play
e5 if i was black just kill the dark
squared bishop
and let the light square bishop in
rather than deal with the dark square
bishop on the diagonal
yeah like one of the bishops are gonna
is gonna be um
powerful but yeah it's it's great like
your bishop
your bishop got to b2 on move five and
didn't move for the rest of the game but
it was one of like your key players
throughout
and i never felt like i had to spend
time developing it like it just sort of
got developed
for me that's very true
yeah that was smooth yeah that's a nice
thing like another
like tidbit with the c5 move on move on
to
just transpose into a gambit of your
choosing yep
and i think um i'm just on the analysis
board but i think another one
that we haven't really mentioned it's
not too special but just any time
against the french against the sicilian
that you can consider the wing gambit i
find it
like really works well just you get a
quick bishop
often on b2 or a3 and
you know the the dark squares in the
center um just the the way that you can
attack in general especially
against like the french or something
in this line uh whenever you have like a
pawn on
on e5 and i can't put a knight there
it's just the likelihood of somebody
getting
gifted is so high that's very true yeah
i've actually
um i used to show this as like one of
the main weapons against the french
to to students like in the
1000 to 2000 range
because it's relatively obscure and
uh like once you if you get this
position it's so easy to play for white
because the center like you're going to
get in d4 the center is not contested
you have i mean there's a positional
trap of getting your knight to
d6 and i think you hit the nail on the
head which is that
the center can't be contested like most
of the time when players play the french
as white
especially at the lower levels like
they'll just run into issues where
they'll they'll have their entire center
just be undermined by moves like this
like simple stuff and they will like
play bishop here and lose b2
or they'll block d4 with knight t2 or
something like that and they'll hang
upon and it's so
so common um that the center falls apart
like
as soon as this pawn drops the e-pun
often drops right after
so that happens all the time yeah
no there's so many um i mean there's a
lot of tricky lines against the french
it's the one
maybe one of the defenses that like i
have the most amount of
just fun openings to play against um
right like there is uh oh man of course
there's enochmanson
if you want to get an open position
against a french player
it's so fun because like all after queen
d3 it's
uh i like this a lot i like this a lot
yeah i played this
against varakovian he's been playing the
french for 30 years
never seen it before
i think i saw i don't know if it was a
video but i definitely i definitely saw
that game
yeah yeah it's on youtube um you can
also
so you can play the the do i call it
nagmansen um orthochop
um you can play the ortho schnapp
against
uh if you play c4 e6 you could play e4
here
yeah so a few different move orders um
yeah and then kudos again to uh jonathan
trance
i think i i said nagminson because i was
thinking about uh
jonathan trunts and like all all his uh
yeah and a few other like french lines
like this b3 line is kind of cool
usually ends up being a gambit after d5
you sack the e-pawn and then
there's a cool line g4 and you do stuff
this looks nice i think there's a lot of
success to be had with like
um random fianchettos like this one
looks looks really nice the other one is
when
like when people play the closed
sicilian
i think it's really normal for people to
play like e65
almost as a reflex and we were talking
about the grand prix but
um i think this is pretty underrated um
opening where they play d5 kind of
automatically
and after like bishop here or even
bishop b5 is an idea but the point is
you go bishop here and you hit the pawn
and
you know there's this like thing with
knight f6 where you kind of have to deal
with
bishop g5 hitting you at some point
and um you you basically deal with
d4 by going knight d5 and you get this
weird position where the the guy's gonna
like
check you really soon and bishop b6 is
like often met by
you know knight f4 which is kind of
annoying so
like really really quickly it's like
easy to
go wrong in in this position i find yeah
no i think the common theme with a lot
of the openings we're discussing
is like we're we're getting of the early
lead in development
and then it creates more opportunities
for the opponent to fall into traps or
just to create
difficult situations for the opponent to
develop
i think this was actually a fischer
spassky game or spassky fischer
um i've have a clear memory of them
going into this
variation i think they went into the 95
line
at some point
yeah i don't know anything about like
this that's the one thing is like
i think most of the things that i play i
haven't even
um i haven't ever checked the engine
not even once because i'm almost worried
that i'm always worried he's gonna spoil
the fun that's interesting so i actually
i use the engine
almost always when when stud
like just studying on my own just to get
its perspective
um and i don't care if it's like if it
gives me my position like
a terrible evaluation but sometimes it
will offer like ideas i wouldn't
normally consider
i think what you're learning about me is
i just don't study chess
that's the maybe a small problem but
that's the least
yeah but sometimes like you like if
you're playing on stream
you can quickly check and that's how i
study a lot these days
like playing and then checking real
quick
should we do one more game yeah yeah go
for it i'm hungry for another stafford
gambit
again so i'm just going in order like
i'm rewarding the people who are patient
hey i'm black okay i'm gonna pre-move
do my um my pre-move repertoire
oh i have to play in england
yes d4 e5 and
hopefully whoever this is was not
watching the game
yeah i'm just pre-moving every move yeah
that's what you do
i'm gonna try and flag the point with oh
no my knight oh
but white doesn't take it and he was
really ready for it
yeah that's crazy i guess he knew it was
coming
okay yeah this will happen every time
and again
so um gm derek who i
discovered this trap from has
recommended
that black goes for like this early
queenside castling yeah i can only
imagine
that's we'll play c6 first
maybe not let's just develop
i was just preaching about developing
quicker than the opponent
so try and live up to that
yep looks solid
yeah all i want is a position with
opposite side castling
which it looks like we're getting you're
going to get that
yeah that's a good move unfortunately
i don't really want to trade queens
so this to me is the the bane of the
existence of this
opening yeah simply knight c3 knight e4
forces an extremely uncomfortable bishop
exchange or queen trade and both are
undesirable
yeah no i'm like this is where i
probably use the engine
to see of course after the game like
see what it would recommend if there's
any ideas to
to deal with this uh from lights
this is definitely um the highest
impact trick in the opening but like
also in some ways to me it has the
lowest floor
like yeah the the position that you can
get especially
a guy just knight c3 knight b5 or knight
e4
um seems to kind of force what what
white wants and i
i haven't been able to really get out of
it that's unfortunate
i'm actually considering going
completely insane here
let's do it so i'm going to avoid like
some
bad structure if um if knight takes d6
i'll take with knights
and g4 yeah so this is what i was
looking at
i'm kind of losing a piece but only kind
of
but only kind exactly
uh what's my idea
you're probably long castling and then
preparing some stuff
what was your ending uh a good question
so what does he do after long castle
because it looks like you take
on f5 no like rook takes e6
i kind of want to take on g4 first
to have the pawn as a target and then
castle
but then i lose a knight i guess i'll
just i'll move back and then
now i'm threatening g4 and i'll have h5
coming
and the good thing about you know 1473
rated opponent
after each five as soon as there's
tension on the board everyone always
captures they
they don't think twice the file is
guaranteed to open
exactly just a matter of when
and even if i'm down material and down
on time i'll have compensation
in the form of rating
rate income plus the plus 1100. yeah
and like okay there's actually like
compensation in the position too
i have a threat i've identified the
problem with your threat
is if you execute your threat on taking
the pawn on g4
you can never open the h file again oh
that's true
so it's better he defended it
uh i'm so reckless here
i hope there's no small children
watching oh
well this is perfect this is really
yeah there's bishop to b5 ideas but
you've reached the
twilight zone this is you know i think
the two-piece deficit
territory is where most dubious things
come to life
it's true okay
gotta lose all the pawns and open all
the files
he's a dangerous bishop g4 guy
yeah that's okay he's i'm losing more
pieces
does it work it might work oh maybe it
doesn't work
am i meeting probably not
ah don't do it i definitely think it's
still possible
ah you did it okay
we're about to find out queen takes d6
would be oh my d-pawn
damn it
okay this is why dirty flagging is it
exists
exactly why else
perfect i mean just pristine execution
gotta deliver the spike checks
oh he's speaking of spike checks wow
titan tanner little smokes this is a
tough
game i'm not proud of that game
[Music]
what a game yeah
yeah when it when it doesn't when it
doesn't go go well
it usually goes very downhill that's
that's pretty typical
but i still think if you long castled i
i
i think he would have been in trouble i
think he would have thrown him off
although he played some really good
chess to be honest he kind of defended
and
like made his own threats as well he
never let up
yeah definitely um
no the uh
i think that the play overall was was
very solid from light
this time was the culprit in the end
yeah
yeah i'm not sure um
i'm just checking the engine to see like
so like i
i haven't really ever looked at this but
i don't like this
being just like an unpreventable thing i
feel like if i played this
again i might consider something like
knight g6 or knight f5
just encourage more captures and then
get more open lines and definitely avoid
any shenanigans on like
queen trades or knight takes my bishop
that's interesting yeah there's an idea
i was pondering the other day
of like in this position instead of
pre-moving 97
pre-moving pawn f6
where so after takes here then
i it's not the same sort of trap
you're trying to increase the the amount
of baiting that you're doing
right that 97 is almost too obvious and
this is like
oh man i you know he he was supposed to
maybe take this way
and now that he's gotten away with this
it's so natural to keep going
and f6 might make a little more sense in
the position
um but maybe it's similar that light's
going to come to e7 anyway
so um yeah this takes further work this
is kind of like a one-trick opening
it is it is it really is uh for the
shock value and the more people
talk about it then it's just too easy to
prevent e3 is also kind of a natural
move so some people are going to block
it accidentally
that's true yeah but i've tried
the online opening database
and like the most common moves for white
are the ones which fall into the trap
like these are all the most common moves
and then this is played
i think more than 50 of the time
that makes sense so i mean there's not
too many games in it but
uh obviously yeah maybe there will be
there will be more after uh after this
stream i'm gonna have a youtube video on
this at some point
yeah yeah exactly no the this one is
like
really really good and there are just
some that are
as we said more shock value like the
ceiling is super hot you pretty much
immediately win the game
or the floor can be a little like kind
of a rough position
or simply the the trick of the opening
fizzles out in
essentially any game where they're not
taking your knight they're
it's just a regular game pretty much
that's true yeah
yeah kind of some risk versus reward
scenario
yep exactly but there's definitely um
there's definitely some like it's nice
to have a repertoire like if you're
really interested in this stuff and you
sort of don't want to deal with too much
theory
it's like yeah pre-move e5 as you're
saying have a
have a tricky opening that you can play
against literally anything and a move
that
you're ready for no matter what yeah
like i think for me i i have different
repertoires
for obviously over-the-board chess but
then also
for blitz and bullet against strong
players and then
blitz against weaker players like um
sometimes you just adjust to who you're
playing and what the format is
yeah i think probably the
the opening that i've i've actually
played it like
a significant amount of times over the
board probably with an average rating of
about 2 000 but
up to maybe 2 300 and it's
not really a secret of any sort but i
play like this
owens like all the time interesting and
it's kind of my my favorite opening like
hands down
like it really is my favorite because
the most
likely situation if everyone plays
sort of very obvious moves is that you
end up
in this position and they just
defend everything the way they should
and
the amount of success that stems from
this particular position is kind of
crazy that
after bishop d2 you you always take and
if they take with the pawn you go knight
c6
and really really common is let's say
the castle or something
that's fine you sort of play like knight
a5 h6 and you're all about the light
squares
but some people will take because they
realize that there's no
like 94 or no 95 and
although they've planned knight a5 queen
g4 um
it's i think it's pretty much losing for
white after this
like i guess just like yeah
so much pretty much everything happens
pretty much everything happens at once
and as you can imagine there's
lots of like quite pretty checkmates and
whatnot thinking like two-ish yeah
all sorts of stuff like you know i've
had this many times
just kind of cute but yeah white
positions all natural moves too
yeah the position is like really comfy
and if they take with the bishop
the amount of times that after just
quick c5 the amount of people that
blunder their
their bishop to this trick is just c4
yes and it's just crazy
it's just crazy yeah this is my favorite
yeah i've never really explored like the
main i guess the main
lines for black with b6
yeah it all it all stems from like this
d5 move and there's so many ways to play
it like some people
just have a preference to go for a quick
d5 they'll go
like c5 but i'm always trying to like
pretty much give this bishop away
and put so much pressure that eventually
should either get them taking or pushing
either way i think mostly yeah it's all
about the light squares for me
is there a line with f5 i i have some
big memory of like
f5 i don't know if it's if it's bad for
black
so f5
like bishop d3 f5 yeah f5 i think
it works for white if i'm not just
like it's i think it wins for white but
they have to know like
15 moves gotcha or something like like
really really specific moves
um so yeah the rule is generally if the
bishop's on f8
f5 is bad like according the engine but
it's really fun i know there's like
specifically videos out there on youtube
that outline
exactly like every single move you have
to know here
so those are kind of fun too because
it's like you know if they
if they don't know what's what's going
on you have
this stuff i think it's bishop g7 and
the king goes over
some knight g5 but if white makes one
blender it's like boom just like black
wins or something
yeah i guess this is where engine
preparation would come in
yes this is where you bust out an engine
and
try to solve it if you want to try it um
it's worth a try
maybe but just know i think the
evaluation is pretty significant for
for white here if they play right yeah
it's not something i've really
dug into so much yep but there is one
line
i um i guess i discovered
recently i first discovered it by just
searching ray robson's games
and saw he plays it and then then
jonathan trance made a video about it
it's called the nozzle loss
the nozzle i mean did they name it
themselves
i think it's like one of the if you just
play the moves it's what
chess.com should tell you right um
so in this position after bishop b7
you can play bishop g5
yeah the nozzle was so one
so the nice thing about this if it's
bullet
i've trapped so many people like
recently with e6 and then
because people pre-move e6 and you just
take the queen exactly
but then it's a gambit too like if they
take the free pawn
you play d5 and the bishop can't return
to its home
and then you attack the bishop with
tempo e6 pawn is
or e7 pawn is pinned and there's some
cool
i mean there's just fun to be had in
this position for white
but all it takes is a simple idea like
you can start with the idea of
uh yeah don't let this guy have his
bishop on this diagonal that's where
he's comfortable and
don't let him play e6 ever and then
that's as an idea is enough to like
build an entire opening around it and
just yeah simple exact
simple idea and simple foundation yeah
and engine
i've checked this with engine and it
gives like close to equal so that's
probably sufficient compensation for
white's uh
being down the pawn yep
that looks solid and and the the only
other funny one i can think of at the
moment
is you you've probably seen it but it's
the one that that hikaru uses to
to beat like every grand master
in his oh is bishop a3
yeah this is probably one of my favorite
sort of i would say on this on the
higher end level of things high level
opening just because it's kind of built
around i don't even know the
the exact opening moves
yeah i think i actually first saw this
in like an agmater video
um and it's just so natural that
yeah you went back upon
[Music]
yeah this is nice and you just win this
pawn
and then you like take the knight and
like plant your knight on d4
it's a disaster yeah and white style up
looks so non-threatening here too
yeah and you're not expecting like the
vision you just
the whole position crumbles for lack
yeah
yeah so this is not like it's pretty
specific but
um i think at the higher level it's fair
to say that what black has done
is so common honestly so he really gets
like
tons of gms if i played fiance which i
don't i'm sure he'd get me as well but
i just luckily haven't encountered it
yeah i know there's this whole other
category of like um
i guess opening traps or like even like
small nuances
that are still effective at high level
play
that maybe we don't touch on because
we're playing amateurs all the time
but um yeah this is this is a big
passion of mine especially when it comes
to preparing for players to find
even like small small tricks in the
opening to
um to throw the opponent off and get
even some small advantage
definitely so definitely there's one
i'll just share one in the london
uh i'm i would imagine you've seen it by
now but this line with um
[Music]
e6 b6 this queen f3 line
like stockfish lila approved engines
will give like plus point
five and they're like there's cool ideas
with like knight c3
eventually pawn storm on the king side
just super fun opening to um
to look into and like a lot of players
just haven't seen this move before
even at the top level and
is there some sort of queen g3 that
happens eventually
uh so first of all black has to commit
either knight c6 or d5
which is usually yeah there are two
moves that you don't really want to play
in the structure
um imagine
yeah imagine d5 eventually
yeah we do want to um probably play g4
and then queen g3
but we can start with like 92 castling
and then
do the king side stuff yeah the the
queen f3
followed by like g4 is always really
nice because the queen always protects
the rook on h1 i think it's the best
feeling you could possibly have like
launching the pawns forward
yeah if you ever like if black ever
plays h6 you can safely play g5 and not
worry about the
each file opening yep oh this reminds me
oh
one of my uh favorite
dumb dirty openings it's like a long
kind of line
but it's like it's super fun and bullet
because you just get so much initiative
and it's relevant to this h file opening
uh okay dumb and dirty let's go yeah
i'll quickly show it it starts with a
budapest
i haven't played it in a while actually
because i've been playing this england
garbage but um
a buddha pass gambit
umass like has a bunch of traps that uh
are like pretty well known but this is a
bit lesser well-known
so main move here is bishop f4
and then we play bishop b4
knight d2 is main move and then d6
and it's just a super fun gambit like
after he takes
queen f6 and white has all these targets
and i guess i was reminded because
there's a line where the h file opens
like the most natural move for white e3
we play g4 and the fact that queen's
defending the rook is relevant
because after this we want to trap the
bishop
white plays h3 we still attack the
bishop
and then we do this weird trade thing
like takes takes
takes takes and then imagine takes and
then takes
just the possibly the worst pawns to
ever exist
yeah like white structure is hilarious
and we're threatening takes takes takes
and winning everything
and if if knight f3 defending we do this
and again we're fighting takes takes
takes
so yeah and this doesn't really help
whites
no usually taking the c7 helps black
which is kind of funny
counter-intuitive yeah we just develop
and the pawn's going to be weak
yeah this is great the budapest has the
problem with the budapest is that i feel
like if they
give the pawn back i'm never a huge fan
of it but that's like with any
gambit there's always like nothing lines
that aren't too
nice to play against but the upside is
so high
well i i have i can show a few like
lines against
the the buddha like if you're white here
there's a few traps you can play against
budapest
um one of which someone just like
randomly commented
in like in a youtube comments and i
looked into it and it was like engine
approved
it was really cool i had never seen it
before
is knight g4 e3 takes and then f4
knight g6 is natural and then h4
yeah an engine will just give this as
like um
like pleasant advantage for white if we
if black takes and
uh i think there's there's random like
just central compensation better
development
half open each file yep
yeah not so easy to castle king side
yeah but then okay then i have a more
like concrete trap
which i fell into i fell into like a few
times before i realized like what i
should do against it
uh white can play not a three here
allowing
black to do this thing and provoking e3
so usually like black's happy to shut in
this bishop
and then black will go after and win the
pawn now key move
bishop d2 imagine black wins upon
white trade is now bishop c3
now what would you play as black here
e6 i would play this d6
d6 uh looks natural a loses a piece
uh white is winning a piece after b4
and it's nice yeah like it's not too
often like gets the bishop on c3 so
early
but um it's a reason to go for this
early idea and then
and we can take and eventually trap the
bishop
nice so yeah very innocuous bishop d2
like it's not really up to anything
seemingly yeah no
again it looks like non-threatening and
um
[Music]
but it has this this clever idea and i
like the fact that it starts with e3
because e3 the amount of times that
people just hang their knight
and just play knight c6 is actually
overwhelming because they're so used to
white playing knight f3 that's true yeah
like
usually as black you're getting ready to
play knight c6
so anyway i've like i feel like we were
like continually tangenting
yeah yeah every everyday territory
every like one thing will remind of
something
else like as soon as you did the london
you of course reminded me of the
like the the best london uh
trap which is h5 yeah
so it's like you know something will
remind me of this and this will remind
us something else so
we could be here for for ages yeah
but i think we covered some uh covered
so many different things
so people uh maybe learned a thing or
two
yep or maybe uh know which openings
they're going to take up
now we might you know apologies in
advance to
everyone in the you know sub 1500 range
who has to deal with these
for a bit more often for the next week
yeah like you you can learn how to use
these traps but then you also have to
kind of
understand how to not get trapped
yourself
yes yeah quickly identify which ones
could be coming at you because
there are certain ones you're going to
have to deal with with certain opening
repertoires like if your
e4 player d4 player can adjust
accordingly
definitely yeah yeah i mean these days i
don't really consider myself
one or the other i'm just like all
around like
continue to to experiment
so anyway this is great we should um i'd
be happy to do this again like again i
could spend hours and hours
probably days or years talking about
these sort of books
no absolutely this is definitely fun i i
i think that it's fair to say that um
i haven't really like obviously we
haven't um collab but i don't think i've
really done this type
of thing where it's like a slightly more
serious approach because that people
always see me do
shenanigans and random openings but it's
like okay it's a little more serious
where you can actually
take a few notes and kind of apply these
to
your games and stuff so i mean uh if
people liked it i'm
definitely definitely down to to do it
again and get some more games in
it's always nice i guess when people get
to see it in practice that's what really
sells it's like
yeah we can talk about these cool traps
but it's when you like
play it and people actually fall for it
that it's like wow
this actually works even at that level
whatever it is
definitely yeah i mean um
i i think people appreciate the
educational value
and uh yeah i'm seeing some kind words
in chat
more and more and more yeah people
people on my channel have actually been
bugging me for a little bit to
get in touch with you about this sort of
stuff so i'm glad they did and i know i
know that a lot of people here have a
great deal of appreciation for you
that's awesome i appreciate that yeah
and uh yeah i might be happy to
to do this again um i am i'm really
tired right now i played like two and a
half hours of tennis earlier
i'm on a weird schedule like i went to
sleep at like 7
30 p.m last night so you're so i'm up
past my bedtime
yeah i got you but you you obviously
have a tennis dome
a uh like an indoor uh outdoor
oh it's still warm enough okay yeah
sorry i just you know canadian is you
know
minus minus 10 plus over here you know
it's uh there's snow on the ground
yeah it's still like decent autumn
weather here
it's like it was in the mid 50s
fahrenheit
you know what that translates to but um
warm it was nice yeah no yeah still
tennis weather yeah we were
able to live stream it and the sun was
out oh wow yeah
okay now you're gonna have to stop the
story right there and we get too jealous
anyway um yeah i'm gonna wrap things up
are you gonna keep streaming
yeah so we we usually stream like a
thursday night
uh stream so i thought that like um that
this would be a perfect
kind of warm up for the evening and i
know people aren't gonna learn anything
for the rest of the night
uh so i thought we'd get our session in
in right now so
yeah this was this was great honestly
yeah got to get that education
out of the way before you can have fun
eating the veggies first nice yeah so
i'm gonna probably wrap things up with
my chat and then uh
and send a raid over oh that's very nice
yeah well i know what uh what it's like
being
too tired to stream yesterday i i was
just dead so i had to cut it so i had
would have energy for today but that's
uh that's nice of you buddy well
i'm glad you uh you agreed to do this
this was a lot of fun i think people
enjoyed it and like
like you said i mean i echo your um
sentiment would be totally down to do it
again so we'll be in touch
sounds good yeah definitely be in touch
yeah thanks for everything
yeah thanks sir take care you too bye
bye